>> Announcer: From the Library
of Congress in Washington, DC.
[ Pause ]
[ Applause ]
>> McLean: Thank you very, very much
for these luminous performances.
It's been a tremendous
joy to have you
and the Bach Collegium Japan
here again at the Library,
and to have the time to share a
few of our treasures with you.
This afternoon we had the
pleasure of looking with you
and your colleagues at
the original manuscript
of Bach's cantata number
ten, and your exhilaration
at encountering this manuscript
was tremendously infectious.
Can you talk a little about what
that means for you-the experience
of encountering an
original score like this.
>> Suzuki: Well-well, still
my heart is already beating
so it's...I'll try to calm down.
Well, all the time this-- -
we have seen a wonderful
original autograph this afternoon.
Those original manuscripts,
especially autographs
of Johann Sebastian Bach
himself, inspires us very much,
because he has written not only
the notes but sometimes slurs,
indications of articulations,
and so on-all the details are
very, very interesting to see.
You can never sense
these kinds of things
from the printed material of course.
So, of course the Neue Bach
Ausgabe-that's a new Bach
edition-helps us a lot, but still
we should [at] all time trace
to-actually anything
procedural-from the original source
until the material,
the printed and so on.
So this is a really
great pleasure, yea.
>> McLean: You know, there was
a little phrase at the bottom
of the page that you noticed-at the
very bottom underneath the staves.
Tell the audience about that.
>> Suzuki: Yea, that's
very interesting.
Here is one of the most important
materials of the cantata number 10,
"Meine Seel erhebt den Herrn"-this
is the German magnificat,
and the [inaudible] score.
And, on the edge of the
first page Bach has written
down a couple bars
right next to that page
that means...the one thing
probably he has made an attempt how
to the polyphonic line
works out and so on.
But at the same time
when he has finished
with the first page probably he
could not turn [the page] over yet,
because the ink is still wet.
So that's why before he
forgets the next couple
of bars he has written
down on the edge.
So that's really interesting things.
[ Laughter ]
>> McLean: And you said that's
very rare...you hadn't seen that...
>> Suzuki: Yes, very, very rare.
>> McLean: This is the kind
of thing that you learn
when you're looking at these.
And you mentioned that the
parts are actually more valuable
for a performer than the score.
>> Suzuki: Well actually,
at the time no big machine
so the parts must be
made from the score.
So, probably at that time the set
of parts...performing parts is
more important than the score,
because if you get the parts
then you can immediately perform
the piece.
So, that's why when
the...after his death
in 1750 all the original material,
Bach himself, divided in two.
In one is the score and some duets,
and the other group
is the set of parts.
This set of parts [is]
thought probably more valuable
than the score.
>> McLean: And you mentioned
that one half would go
to his family and others...
>> Suzuki: Yes.
One score and duet going
to one part/ person
and the other sets going
[to the] second person.
Bach has written down in principal
all the detail articulations
and indications of slurs,
and so on-not in the score,
instead they're only
in the parts directly.
On the parts [are] all
the notes what could be
by [Bach's] copyist-his
assistant or sons and so on.
But, after that he has always looked
through and checked all the details.
At the same time he has added
many indications of slurs
and also figuration[s]
of the basso continuo.
So, on the parts the notes are
usually copied by someone else,
but all the detail indications
are by [Bach] himself.
>> McLean: It was a
wonderful, wonderful time.
Critics talk about-- - of
course write about you-- -
your performances as
impeccable, revelatory,
and imbued with spiritual
rigor, and if we had time
for a mystical conversation
we could talk
about how you inculcate
these kinds of qualities
in teaching-in your students.
So, we don't really have time
for that, but I was wondering
if you'd comment on some
of the remarks you've made
about the technique end of things.
And you say that you suggested
that people think theatrically.
>> Suzuki: Yea, someone said
that life is the theater.
Bach's music is so
dramatic and I think
that all the technical aspects
go together with the idea
of the music-not only
music, but the expression.
So techniques are always developed
by this kind of idea, musical idea,
and then how...it's very important
to get a musical idea or what kind
of expression you want to make.
That makes the technique better.
So, those two things
always go together.
At that time, for example, he has
published a couple of collections
of harpsichord pieces called...under
the title of "Clavier-Übung."
Clavier-Übung means
actually "for practice."
Clavier-Übung is the practice.
So at that time the practice meant
for probably...to get an
idea to...to become able
to make a...this and
that expression.
So, it's not only the
moving fingers and so on.
In the Baroque time
this kind of motion
of the fingers [was] always
closely connected to the expression.
So probably after the
Czerny or Beethoven time,
you see the piano technique[s]
are more developed,
and probably it was needed to be
trained a little more mechanically.
So that's why, for example,
etudes of Czerny and so on,
is completely different
ideas-certain concepts
from the Baroque time.
Baroque time is still...everything
was very well related together.
>> McLean: Fascinating.
Well we...maybe a question
about your recordings
and then I know some people in the
audience will have some questions.
Now that you have completed a
staggering fifty-five CD set
of the complete Bach cantatas,
and of course this month you've
just had a big Gramophone Award
for your organ works CD,
you have a lot going on.
And you made a recording with your
son I believe-the harpsichord.
Maybe talk a little about
how you're at this pinnacle.
>> Suzuki: Yea, well we have indeed
completed the church cantatas sadly.
Well, there's no more
church cantatas
to record, that makes me very sad.
But, we are still going on
with the secular cantatas
and the vocal works.
We are doing also harpsichord works
and the...you mentioned the CD
with my son is a two harpsichord CD.
My son is now active
as a harpsichordist
and conductor, and so on.
It was a great pleasure.
We have played all the time at home,
you see the two harpsichord
concerti and so on.
And well one day, we [said]
"why don't we make one CD."
And then we found a CD company
and they found it a very nice
idea so we did that one CD.
And there comes probably
one more CD of concerti
with the three harpsichord,
and four harpsichord,
and so on that needs to me recorded.
Well, many things.
Actually, I have almost completed
the harpsichord solo works as well,
but there are still three
or [inaudible] missing.
And in between I could not wait
for the organ complete series
because otherwise I'm getting
to old to play organ works.
So, I started organ works as well.
>> McLean: You also are
doing Mahler and Mendelssohn-
I mean you have many projects.
>> Suzuki: Yea, well that's
not for recording yet,
but there are plenty
of wonderful music.
Since a couple of years [ago]
I have been asked to work
with the symphony orchestra.
At the beginning they
asked me to do Bach,
but actually I don't
think it works very well
with Bach's music-with
the symphony orchestra,
because setting-wise
and instrument-wise.
Of course, I don't think
it's impossible to do Bach
with modern instruments,
but still the organization
and the concert structure-the
concert activity-[is] not always
appropriate for the Bach thing.
So that's why I have offered some
Mozart, Beethoven, and Mendelssohn.
And I love since a long
time Mahler and Stravinsky.
[A] Stravinsky CD is coming out
probably in a couple of months.
So, well I'm trying to make
my life as buy as possible.
>> McLean: Well you've
said music is the food
that nourishes you every day,
so this is how you have
this extraordinary energy.
>> Suzuki: Yea, it is.
>> McLean: Well perhaps there
are just a couple questions here
from someone.
>> Audience member: I did have one
question that is going to deal more
with orchestras, because I saw you
earlier with the Baltimore Symphony.
You sort of answered
that question already.
Who are you doing the Mahler [with]?
>> Suzuki: Mahler I have
only done in Japan...yet.
But I find [it] so nice to work with
wonderful orchestra like Baltimore
and we did also New York
Philharmonic and together
with my choir, and well
Boston Symphony, and so on.
There's quite many
symphony orchestras
that I...love working with them.
Because of the...this kind
of orchestra musicians
are a little bit different
from our members of course.
The instruments are completely
different and the concept
of the music-making is
quite much different,
but still the good orchestra or good
musicians will have always this kind
of [inaudible] to come closer and
also we can talk about the music
and feeling, and so on, which
is really, really fascinating.
>> Audience member: Do you
have any plans...I don't know
that you've recorded
like the Mendelssohn
"Elijah"...do you have
any plans to record it?
>> Suzuki: No.
Actually, I have planned already
here [points to head] Mendelssohn
"Paulus" and the "Elijah" is of
course one of the most important.
We have done with my choir and
orchestra "Paulus" a couple
of times, but still we
cannot afford to make the CD.
So, if you can help
us then we can...
[laugher] what we need is this help.
>> Audience member: You've
performed all over the world
and I'm just curious, could you give
a sense of the different reactions
of audiences in different
parts of the world,
especially in Germany and Leipzig.
I know they've honored you, but
is there a special reception
that you get when you
perform in Germany?
>> Suzuki: Well, that is a
very interesting question,
because...Of course we expect all
of the time different reactions
from the different country, but
actually there are so many fans
of Bach's music everywhere
in the world and...if you have a
really good audience then there's
more of a similar excitement
that we share all of the time
with the audience and members.
That's not so different
as you expect.
But still, of course, in Japan
it's completely different.
Japanese audiences
never standing up.
The standing ovation
doesn't exist in Japan.
But that doesn't mean to
[inaudible] something less.
[inaudible].
Yea, for example in America,
or in Germany for example.
The German audience is the
closest being for the Bach's music.
They have very personal experiences
with this and that Bach piece.
For example, when we
performed a couple of cantatas,
quite many people came to me
after the concert and [said]
"this cantata was performed in
the funeral of my mother..."
or something like that.
Those kind of personal
experiences...this is really nice
thing I think.
They can appreciate the
word by word, of course.
[inaudible] This kind
of detailed reaction is
of course very interesting.
But in general, in
American or in everywhere,
[it's] a wonderful reception...so
we're having this all the time.
>> McLean: As you were tonight.
Maybe one more question?
>> Audience member: I
thought the pitch is lower.
It's not 440, right?
>> Suzuki: No, this
is the 415 tonight.
It's one half-tone lower than
the usual standard nowadays.
This is the kind of
compromised modern version
of Baroque interpretation.
In Baroque time there was no
standard pitch-so city-by-city
or venue-by-venue [there] was [a]
completely different pitch used.
For example, in France
it is much lower.
Probably one whole tone lower,
so around 390 or 392, and so on.
While in Northern Germany
[inaudible] much higher pitch.
Something like 465 or even
until 480 or -85, and so on.
If you compare with the modern
piano the range is from F-sharp
until B-natural, or
something like that.
So that's all each note can be
said of A-that is the problem.
Bach himself has used the
two different pitch[es]
very intentionally.
The one is a quarter [inaudible]
around organ pitch,
that means around 465.
The other [inaudible]
pitch is around 415.
This gap is exactly one whole-tone.
So that's why in all Bach's
original parts of cantatas,
the organ part is written down
a whole-tone all the time.
So transposed down all the time.
Organ was sort of the transposing
instrument, while the oboe,
wind section, and stringed
instruments are tuned
on the same pitch.
That is a really complicated thing.
Probably you are falling
asleep...from the explanation
of this kind of thing.
[ Laughter ]
>> McLean: Wonderful.
Well you know we hate to stop, we
wish we could keep you several days.
But we do need to stop
because of the police-the door.
Thank you so much!
[ Applause ]
>> Announcer: This has
been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.